[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz klassisches
rezept das ist das tiramisu und es
gehört wirklich zu den klassikern
schlechthin wenn ich eins nicht kann
dann ist es wirklich ein schlechtes
tiramisu essen und manchmal machen dass
menschen einfach nicht so ganz gut
ein thema das so ist habe ich dann gut
wenn sie cremig schmeckt daher verwende
ich auch nur die eigelbe und nicht das
eiweiß noch mit dabei denn eiweiß macht
das trm so luftig und eigelb eben eher
cremig und was eben auch ganz wichtig
ist dass ihr ganz frische eier habt ich
nehme immer bio eier vom bauern und wir
verzehren sondern auch noch am gleichen
tag das kann auch mal sein dass ich
abends zubereitung wir es uns am
nächsten mittag aber da bin ich dann
eher doch vorsichtig und da kommen am
gleichen tag verzehren die zutaten sind
wirklich total übersichtlich ganz
einfach und deswegen starten wir auch
direkt ich verwende fürs tiramisu acht
sehr frische eigelbe 120 gramm
puderzucker ein kilo mascarpone etwa 300
gramm löffel biscuit 300 gramm kaffee
ich habe zehn espresso damit schön stark
ist hier könnt ihr gerne noch amaretto
europa nehmen oder amaretto als zusatz
zum kaffee und noch etwas kakaopulver
und kakaopulver damit meine ich immer
back also kein cover oder nesquik nichts
mit zucker sondern wirklich einfach
doris kakaopulver und jetzt starte ich
direkt und zwar nehme ich jetzt erstmal
die eigelbe die kommen hier in die
rührschüssel wenn ihr sagt ihr seid
nicht so die rohen ei es dann probiert
doch gerne mal ein anderes rezept aus
denn ich habe auch mal ein fruchtgummi
so gemacht mit quark mit joghurt das
könnt ihr gerne ausprobieren das ist
dann wirklich fruchtig aber das ist
einfach die klassische variante jetzt
kommt hier der puderzucker dazu und die
eier masse wird es mit dem puderzucker
einfach schön schaumig oder cremig
gerührt nicht schaurig cremig
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eimasse schön dickflüssig
und ich kann jetzt hier in der schüssel
die mascarpone ganz kurz verrühren
wichtig ist nicht so lange rühren die
masse sollen später schön cremig werden
und nicht flüssig
[Musik]
nehmt eine etwas größere schüssel als
ich bitte ich wollte dir sparen und
macht hier die ganze schweiz jetzt kommt
ihr mascarpone hier zu einer masse wird
ganz kurz eingeführt die stelle ich
jetzt kurz zur seite und habe jetzt hier
eine auflaufform beziehungsweise einfach
eine schöne große rechteckige form
ihr könnt auch eine glasform nehmen oder
ihr könnt auch das tiramisu in einzelnen
gläsern schichten weil so sitzt schnell
mal unansehnlich aus wenn alle so
reingreifen aber ich mache es jetzt
trotzdem so man kann es ja auch schon zu
schneiden jetzt habe ich hier die löffel
biscuit und stinkt kaffee und jetzt gibt
es mehr entweder aber rettung mit rein
oder wie gesagt amaretto aroma es gibt
auch amaretto direkt alkoholfrei jetzt
nehme ich den löffel biskuitteig sie
hier in die kaffeemischung und legt sie
dann direkt hier in die form ich mache
das ganze später zweischichtig das heißt
hier eine untere schicht und dann kommt
noch eine mittlere schicht rein
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt etwa die hälfte der
creme drauf und bisschen weniger als die
hälfte
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch eine schöne zweite
schicht drauf
jetzt denke ich die löffel bis gewürze
mit der übrigen creme ab ich lasse jetzt
noch ein bisschen was übrig denn ich
mich später noch die creme drauf tupfen
wenn sie im kühlschrank etwas fester
wurde daher jetzt erst mal die kleine
menge das wichtigste ist wirklich nicht
so lange zurück
sobald die maskat ohne zu den bayern
kommt damit die mascarpone einfach schön
fest bleibt
jetzt stelle ich das tiramisu abgedeckt
in den kühlschrank für mindestens 4
stunden damit ständig sinken
[Musik]
kbc noch kleidet die särge leser gefüllt
nicht aus der menge die menge reicht
wirklich nur für die große form
ich habe dann einfach noch mal eine
portion zubereitet und die fülle ich
dann wirklich ganz gerne immer mit einem
spritzbeutel so habt ihr einen schönen
abschluss und es verlängert nix jetzt
kommt hier direkt vor dem servieren
cacau drauf und da habe ich einen tipp
für euch und zwar lege ich hier immer
heiß in zum 7
und ich habe auch ein schälchen wo ich
einfach diesen kakao reis aufbewahren
und dann kommt der kakao drauf und so
landet nicht sofort alles hier unten
sondern ich kann es besser kontrollieren
und dosieren
der reis hält sozusagen den kakao so ein
bisschen zurück
[Musik]
die pflegecreme habe ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt mit lang großen
loch thüle und jetzt kann ich hier
einfach die tupfen auf spritzen
das müsst ihr nicht machen aber ich
finde ganz schön und dekorativ burger
die creme reicht nicht ich muss nochmal
creme machen ich schreibe euch die
angepasste mengenangabe ins rezepte
fertig gefällt mir richtig gut und will
dir sagt die tasten sind mit so
anstrengend dann lasst sie einfach weg
ich habe jetzt eine minimal noch übrig
wie wird eigentlich auch noch rein
passen aber ich lasse jetzt so die kann
man auch so löffeln und hier nehme ich
jetzt auch ganz einfach ein sieg mit dem
reis im innen- und sträuße jetzt drüber
lecker schmecker nicht gucken morath
finden zum problem wenn ich probiere ich
einfach selber das libertäre besser
[Musik]
kamerad wir probieren zusammen tiramisu
kennt jeder von euch ja schon gemacht es
gibt ein paar fallbeispiel muss richtig
vertrauen kann und dann sehen wir ganz
kurz ich kenne ich auch nicht so
schmeckt einfach gut gern kaffee aroma
bittermandel schmidt bei pocking ja da
sehen wir es hinbekommen jahr also ich
muss sagen ich hab eine italienische
schwägerin also von meinem cousin die
frau ist italienerin die dani die machen
einfach das beste therapie so und das
ist einfach auch da nichts rezept ist
einfach ganz klassisch und da braucht
man halt auch nicht mehr zutaten und
wenn man eiweiß dazu macht ich habe das
auch schon machen ein ganzes album nutzt
mit eiweiß aber dann wird es einfach
nicht so cremig und deswegen ist so da
wird ja und nun wirklich falsch ich
musste ja weniger cremig sein da gibst
du siehst auch in der farbe kommen dass
ich schon gelb wegen dem bio eier genau
und jetzt gibt es folgendes noch ganz
wichtig es gibt vor dem brutal auf ihn
ein und ganz brutal brille
da bin ich fast vom glauben da stimmt
ihr italiener würde sieht aber es hat
doch nicht hin so detailliert und mache
ich grüße meine frau roberto ich sagen
welche nachfrage macht braucht es auch
jetzt gut
der heißt robert es war
eingeladen zum echten früh seine
hasstiraden wir haben also mit
sprühsahne gemacht
ich habe auch gesagt es gibt ein
italienisches kannst du schon sehen es
kann auf den tischen hab ich schon
gedacht entschuldigung sprühsahne oder
so
nein nein dagegen die küche kommen
zurück wir haben es mit traditioneller
gemacht also jährlich trägt tiramisu mit
sahne zu machen was ich wirklich war
schon in italien wie kommst du für fünf
jahre knast um es mit den worten eines
weißen mannes zu sagen da kann ja kleine
welt ins kalte wasser schmeißen genau
trotzdem roberta wenn es gesagt wie sehr
das tut mir leid
übrigens sie lieben dich trotzdem liebe
ich trotzdem robert war ein ganz tolles
fließen fachgeschäfte asiatischen
anleger kanada auf fliesen legen kann
auch vermessen ich habe mir so kann man
nichts mehr retten
ist also alles gut aber weiterkommen
ruhig vorbei zur therapie sei neulich
gesagt weil ich immer ist ihr so tolle
sachen und ich bin nie da aber erhalten
da wenn ich was mache ja selber schon
ein hammer
richtig ist und dass hier kann man wie
gesagt entweder abschneiden oder an
löffel ich finde so eigentlich jetzt
auch ganz appetitlich und ich habe es
wie gesagt auch in kleinen gläsern das
innovations- gläser dann hat eben jeder
gleich ein schönes deshalb vor dem tier
schiebe ich nehme jetzt meine gläschen
auch mit zu meiner freundin und das
rezept findet ihr auf cds - blog.de ich
wünsche euch viel spaß machen schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare wie es euch
geschmeckt hat hier doch bis zum
nächsten mal
ob er für max malsch das rezept dazu ist
[Musik]